the guy at the top of the stack the guy
at the top of almost everyone's stack
calimary
continues to be a focal point of
attention of scrutiny of praise of
everything in last week it was the
culinary love fest Chris right and it
was all column and column Ares great
column Ares this and caliber is that he
was great at his press conference and
everything's great he's gonna be the
first overall pick and now is the
backlash peepers I guess people in the
league or sick of calamari because it's
been the Charlie Castle II comments all
week it's this weird idea that he
somehow faked his height at the Scouting
Combine that's something that an unnamed
Scout told dan Patrick how do we process
this notion that we go from loving to
Cuyler Murray collectively to at least
having some within this overall draft
complex hating Collard Murray the next
week well I think a lot of it is just
crap and I think a lot of his talk and
nonsense and not really backed up by
anything I mean you know oh and an
anonymous Scout telling do I know Dan
Patrick probably knows people but at the
same time you know who's who's telling
them what's their agenda we go back into
that same conversation right you know
what what's their connection to the
whole situation in general maybe they
had a bad maybe it's a Scouty at a bad
grade on Cuyler Murray and he saw him
practice and he just thought there's no
way the guy's 510 and then you know here
he's proven wrong that he is 510 oh he
must have done something he must have
gotten some chamber and got stretched
out or hung hung upside down from the
doorframe for the last 24 hours to get
that there's no way he's really that so
to me is a lot of nonsense right now and
of course the Charlie Cassell situation
and all that convo really blew up
yesterday and got interesting which I
know we're gonna talk about here Mike
but which makes me even think it's more
skeptical skeptical to things I mean not
only the way people defended Cuyler
Murray yesterday but the other thing is
the fact that the the Cardinals and
we're hearing that they're not shopping
Josh Rosen so there's two things that
Charlie Cassady said that certainly are
in question here two days out from him
actually saying it yeah but again who
knows whether they are or aren't
shopping Josh Rosen and maybe last week
they were gauging the market that would
be potentially out there hypothetically
in the event that they were to shop Josh
Rosen and that's why I had a problem
with the specificity and the precision
of casa Lee's report
on the notion that he was being shocked
maybe they were just making some phone
calls to see what would be out there so
they know if they pull the trigger on
Cuyler Murray what they could get for
Josh Rosen and maybe this week they're
not shopping him and they aren't going
to be shopping him and I think we're
gonna have reports all over the place on
all of these issues up until the time
comes for the Cardinals to tell the
world who they're drafting well yeah I
mean yes we're gonna hear a lot of crap
and who knows what to believe in all of
that but shopping is different than
talking to people about it shopping is
openly calling around the league going
hey you know Josh Rosen is available
what do you think you'd want now having
people called the Arizona Cardinals as
what which sounded like what it was
really going on because people here
people like us and all the other TV
shows and radios out there that are
talking about Kyler marine it may be
number one them calling the Arizona
Cardinals is a different thing than
shopping and as that Adam Schefter I
believe reported you know nobody could
tell what they were gonna do they didn't
tip their hand in any which way and I'm
sure they don't know what they're going
to do yet so I think shopping might have
been a little bit misleading to their
eye I know but I know they did chef
Heather how do we even know that that's
accurate that's that's it so much of
this stuff now when it relates to this
and it is so strategic it's chess it's
checkers it's chicken all thrown into
one there is so much noise there's so
much smoke and somebody puts their name
to a report and look how do we know how
do we know what's true and what's not
true we don't know what's true until it
actually happens and there are so many
agendas and there are so many strategic
objectives at play here that it's
impossible to know with certainty what's
going on but we do know with certainty
how Calamari's camp is officially
reacting to the charcoal Casserly
comments from earlier in the week I
spoke to Eric Burkhart yesterday who was
hired to represent Cuyler Murray the
full comments appear at pro football
talk column in the radio hour I read all
of them I'm not going to read every last
one of them here but you know it's a
combination of Eric Burkhart defending
kala Merri and then attacking Charlie
Cassell here's what he said to defend
Kyle Emery we're talking about a young
man who has done everything right and
worked relentlessly his entire life to
achieve and push
for greatness we're talking about the
first human ever drafted in the top ten
in two major sports leagues and who just
completed the greatest single season in
football history let me stop there I I
don't know that I would call it the
greatest single season in football
history
I'll give Burkhart a little a little
leeway here because he represents the
guy it was a pretty good seat it was an
awful season it was an awesome season I
don't know it's the single greatest
season ever
but again stretch yes I'm with you he
represents him so he's inclined to say
that yep
you will not find even one former
teammate or coach at any level in any
sport who's played with calimary who has
anything remotely negative to say about
him his leadership or his work ethic so
that's the defense of Kyler Murray and
look I keep going back to this Kris how
can we clean big-picture leadership
attributes about Kyler Murray from a 15
minute Scouting Combine interview even
if these people are telling the truth
- Charlie castling they're not trying to
game the system they're not trying to
make the Cardinals go wobbly and not
draft Kyler Murray that if this is
legitimate opinion that was honestly
fashioned with no agenda involved which
is impossible in this context but even
if it is how do you come to the
conclusion in 15 minutes oh that guy's a
bad leader exactly no I mean you cannot
you cannot come in to that conclusion
certainly not and I think that's where
you know I questioned the whole thing I
mean I just you know again I don't doubt
that Charlie Castle II talked to
somebody who had said some of these
negative things about Kyler Murray now
do why I guess where I question it is it
was it really a GM or somebody that's
really high-ranking official that that's
where I questioned I wonder what want to
know who Charlie Castle II talked about
in this situation was it just some area
scout who's sitting in the back of the
room or sitting on the bed because you
do these interviews in a bedroom right
in the hotel so is this somebody just
sitting in the background who you know
wasn't in love with the way he answered
or how he came off charisma wise or you
know maybe he didn't just blow you out
of the water on the board but you just
can't make these determinations from
there I think again where I go back to
all this and where to me it just seems a
little weird this whole thing you know
guys like you and me we know so many
people around the
fell when guys like this come out in the
draft and Kyla Miran we kind of known he
was gonna be towards a first-round type
pick now for over about three months
right where he's gonna be in the
conversation the heights gonna be the
issues you don't win the heisman all of
those things
there was never rumors or anything out
there like this and I know I'm not like
sitting here trying to be Johnny
breaking-news guy okay but at the same
time I talked to a whole lot of people
and Kyla Marie's come out and come up
many a times through conversations and I
never heard anything negative you know
through the rumor ville which I usually
would hear like like we talked about a
little yesterday when Johnny Manziel was
getting close to his last year at Texas
A&M I knew I knew all the stories
already continued to hear all the
stories and I think what even makes it
more confusing is the way his agent the
way Lincoln Riley backed him up to be so
adamant that this is you know
categorically false I think is that
where you know it kind of opens my eyes
and you know opens up my ears a little
bit more because hey someone that coach
at Texas A&M when some of those bad
things were talking about Johnny Manziel
he didn't come out and start talking in
the news and going this is wrong
Johnny Manziel is awesome he never did
anything off the field wrong because he
knew that wasn't the truth so those are
the things I'm juggling around right now
I guess where I'm having a hard time
digesting it all and Kris on one of the
points that you made about Charlie
Castley and we don't know who he spoke
to in the room he said yesterday on ESPN
Radio New York that he has a plus
sources on this he's not being
manipulated he's not being used of
course that's that's part of a
successful manipulation the person being
manipulated manipulated but that's a
different psychological discussion
altogether we we actually have greater
context and greater specificity from
Burkhart as to how he knows and he
believes and again these people could be
lying but here's what Burkhart said my
business partners and I personally
represent coaches and executives who sat
in on eight of Kyler's 10 formal combine
interview coaches and
I spoke directly to each of them as well
as executives from the other two teams
and many others who I don't represent
but were present and all of them were
extremely positive about his entire
interviews with each citing specific
examples as to why now again they could
be lying to him but there's no reason
there's no that's where I would say
right away
usually agents get the truth you know if
a team wasn't impressed with me or had
issues than me when I came out in the
draft
my agent kind of got the feel from when
he talked to those teams you know
anything you know I don't know if they
love you I don't know if they were in
love with the interview you know there
was things on your film they did so but
he's Burkhart gonna tell us that I mean
let's be fair is he gonna tell he
probably is not going to tell us that no
no you're right I will I will I will
agree with you there he's not gonna go
oh yeah you're right the team's trashed
him so so that is a good point I that's
valid but but but let me say this yes
to the extent that he is trying to cover
something up he he is aggressively
shouting from the rooftops his
opposition to what Castle he said so I
believe that Burkhart believes that Kyla
Marie did a much better job than
casually is suggesting and that's when
he turned in his comments to me
yesterday to casually what do I think
about an agenda driven analyst who's
never once even talked to Kyler's or any
of his coaches or teammates I think it's
disgusting and embarrassing and casually
should be ashamed of himself the bottom
line here is it calls into question the
motives of man to get on national
television and cite anonymous sources on
things such as leadership and study
habits about somebody he's never met and
I want to stop right there because when
we talked about these quotes last hour
we had not connected the dots back to
what the agenda would be this is
something that stats heard yesterday in
listening to Charlie Cassidy's interview
on ESPN New York casually blurted out
that this this attack on the idea that
he wasn't prepared that was part of
casualties quotes from Tuesday that
Conor Murray had a horrible interview
but he wasn't prepared for the interview
and he should have been prepared for the
interview so I don't know whether or not
casually was attacking Murry or whether
he was attacking Burkhart for not
ensuring that Murray was properly
prepared and that's always been very
confusing to me and I'm mindful of a
clock here I think what we need to do
because I think we've figured out
definitively what the agenda may be and
it's fairly obvious and it's very
troubling to me as somebody who's in
this business as to why casually may
have said what he said you know maybe
he's getting manipulated maybe he's
getting used or maybe he has a personal
business interest that would cause him
to be more inclined to trash a guy like
Kyle Armour
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports